Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina
genes.
Are you ready to glass?
Just wow,
son.
Ready to go glass in or what?
Cool.
So loose.
It makes me happy every time.
I know it's the best every single single day too.
It's such a gift that I was testing out this new slack.
We have a,
you know,
new monitor and everything and I was just playing with it and we were running
audio and video through it and we just use that clip and I just was laughing.
Still a man still.
Yeah.
He gets so excited.
Were just glass,
glass and just glass.
So ridiculous.
All right,
let's start the show.
Um,
oh moose.
Do you want to start the show with a clip?
Oh No.
Uh,
holiday spirit or do you like Christmas spirit or do you want to do like a
silly,
silly man?
Well,
we did a silly man last week.
I'm going to do Christmas.
And you love the Christmas season.
I love the holidays.
Yeah,
I do too.
Uh,
I love the Christmas.
and I don't want anybody with diamonds on the crevice of their person.
No,
no,
no.
So let's just go.
So gross.
And I hate that you keep singing it around the house.
I know.
My asshole pucker every time.
All right,
let's do it.
Let's start the show and it's clan.
That was good.
Let's get in the holiday.
Christmas spirit.
Here we go.
Let's glass.
Sure.
Close enough.
Ah,
don't bring in one month into this.
Well,
we'll go to your mom's house.
Mom said Christina.
Okay.
Yeah,
if I'm,
if that sounded weird to you.
It's should it did.
Because we have a replacement computer right now.
He goes,
my logic board was fucked.
Thank you for everybody that messaged me when I asked all those questions last
week,
my Mac book shot.
So that was so weird.
Yeah.
So I have a,
I don't have like my normal drops.
I don't have my normal stuff yet.
So I did,
I realized I didn't have the intro.
So I had blue band record,
basically a version that's played somewhere,
but he doesn't have the actual file.
Real deal.
Yeah.
So that's what we don't have all of our drops.
No,
but I have some.
But you know what that's gonna mean is that we have to invent new ones.
Oh yeah.
Not only that,
but I do have,
I do,
it actually got me into something I'm really excited to do glass for,
of I'm in a glass all fucking day.
But the other thing I'm going to do is,
um,
I went into the archives and you know,
people don't realize,
I think we get 500 plus legit emails a week.
Yeah.
Wait,
I'm saying not,
you know,
people listening and writing in and you can only spend so much time,
looking over your job.
Basically we had to hire someone to do it and then the blue van has another gig
too,
so he can only kind of get,
get through so much and prep all this stuff for the show.
So the other day when I,
when I sent in that computer to get fixed,
I'm using this one,
I went into the archives and I realize there's songs we've missed.
Yeah.
And then other times,
this thing,
we've talked about that before too,
which is songs that have played,
but only once.
And you're such a good fucking song.
They're so amazing.
Yeah.
And they just come and go.
And we were so lucky that people send us amazing shit.
Yeah.
We only use,
can I ask you before I forget?
Yeah.
What are,
are these dicks?
Yeah,
there's decks on her tits,
so I can't leave looking at it.
So for our listeners that,
um,
that don't watch the show,
we put,
you know,
we try to put this up on,
on youtube every week.
Right now,
the clip of the jingle bells lady,
she's um,
she has,
uh,
I guess like pink biker shorts,
but they're pulled up over her pretty sizable midsection.
Um,
Gut,
right?
I mean it's a pretty,
it's a who is she right there?
Yeah.
And then she has a hat on and um,
she,
um,
I dunno,
uh,
a blue band said he,
he doesn't think she's,
well,
100%,
but I don't know.
But then she cut out a paper,
drawings of Dicks and there are they,
what's the,
what's used on her tits to keep them there?
It's like shaving cream.
So she rubbed shaving cream on her tits and then she put paper Dicks on them and
then she sang Chicco Belson.
Well,
Django Bell,
it doesn't,
well she said jingle bells.
I think she's,
I think she's Spanish.
Yeah,
she's,
she's doing the best she can.
Yeah.
Let's see here.
Let's see.
Let's just got the spirit and she's touched.
Oh,
that's a very Spanish,
you know what's neat too is when
do you want,
I really want to know
which is this Christmas say no to Dick.
I think that's what she said.
Love is when people do it in the bathroom.
That's what she said.
It's nice when people do art in the bathroom by the toilet because the acoustics
as you can here are fantastic.
The toilet and then it sounds good,
you know,
because of all the tile and I don't think she's that deliberate.
Yeah.
But what do you think inspired her to do this and why they,
I mean I understand jingle bells because she's obviously into the holiday,
but why this Christmas say no to Dick and Oh my God,
my thing just went to sleep again.
Why that you think?
Well,
she's got a dick problem.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He's got a problem with Dick.
So you gotta say no today.
What is the problem she has?
You think she,
well she finds dicks on the Internet.
That's when I'm guessing.
Yeah.
And,
and they're probably not good dicks.
So wouldn't the solution be just go find better dicks?
You'd think that?
Yeah,
but she'd rather write a song about it and put it on the Internet.
It's so amazing to me that people still do this shit.
They don't even think about their families or jobs.
It's kind of on genes.
What do you mean what's going on?
Help me out man.
Keep talking.
Um,
I didn't realize
I have an interesting story.
I need your help with Tom.
I'm going to need you to pay attention to me eventually,
but I can set it up.
Cause I've told you the premise already.
I went to Washington.
Dick come.
Yeah.
And how was that so much fun?
It's really fine.
Great clubs.
And be honest,
I had such a hard time getting through my sets because the audience unanimously,
they were all shouting your,
the water champion.
You're the water champion about me?
No,
no,
no.
Christina,
your the water and it was like distracted a bunch of losers went to your show.
No,
no,
they're all winners.
They're all mommies.
Um,
but I want to go over something that happened to me.
So I took a lot of sloppy dumps while I was on the road because we don't have
the,
the washlet there said this before sex the other night.
You're telling me about this,
about this lobby dump.
It really was gummy like,
so I was like,
this is a sexy story.
Well that's why I wanted to bring it up on the show because we talked about this
last night before we did it.
They were really turned on.
So I thought maybe turn on the audience.
So I,
during the day I was hanging out just glass and in my room and I had a fart that
it was a hot fart,
but it didn't feel like anything came out.
But then I went to go pee later and I just like,
I went to kind of wipe it up down there and there was brown on the toilet paper.
So
was that a shark?
No,
I need help.
Was that a shark or was it just a little bit of leaky?
But you know what I'm saying?
You went to a p right and you wiped your badge.
Why wipe down?
You got to wipe down,
you wipe front to back.
And I do a thorough,
like
always fun.
Top down.
You always want to push the year end towards the Brown.
You never want to do the opposite.
Right.
He did that and there was brown,
but I was like,
I kind of grazed my be whole now.
I always do just to make sure nothing's going down there.
And there was brown on the toilet paper.
So that makes me think Tom was that,
was that a sharp?
Um,
I think you're the expert.
It's quite obvious that you absolutely sharded.
Do you remember the Fart that yes.
Did you have to have how soon before that p Wipe did you fart?
Well,
that's,
I was in bed and I was reading and it was like a hot fart.
Yeah,
it does.
I'm saying I didn't feel brown coming down.
I just felt like,
oh,
that was a hot one.
And then I went to go potty like 20 minutes later and there was a brown on the
paper.
Wow.
But that other that,
but then I ha,
here's the other part that's telling me the other part and this is where I need
help.
Yeah.
Because I took a really hot,
messy brown that morning because I had a hotel room,
coffee and I,
it was messy and sloppy and I had to go shit to shower on that one.
So my question to you is,
do you think that that was the neverending wipe,
like a residual from my hot brown earlier?
Probably was.
You didn't mention that when you brought up,
did I shark?
Because if you just give me the information,
I farted and then I wiped when I peed and there was brown there.
You're shorted.
But now you're telling me there's a big brown messy wipe earlier bus with messy
brown.
Then it probably,
because I have those sometimes where you're like,
Ooh,
and then you go later on there's all this brown there.
But here's the thing is that I showered after and usually after I shower
thing you left out.
So now the first of all,
I'm really sexually aroused,
really turned the plot,
thickens the brown thing and well that's what I'm saying.
I don't know.
What is it?
Was it a true shark?
Was it a post?
Uh,
you know,
leaky but situation,
I don't know.
Yeah,
it's,
it's really interesting.
Well,
it kind of sharp.
Tell me about sharks in your past.
Maybe I can compare a shark to just like I farted after a bad doubt basically in
the,
maybe it pushed some more brownout oh,
sure it did.
I mean,
you know,
a handful of times.
I'm trying to think of the most recent one.
Um,
but what's it like in your underwear?
Usually?
Usually a shark doesn't necessarily have to get that far because like
your body alarms you so quickly.
It's like a,
but clinch thing takes place.
You know,
you feel the brown coming down.
I mean you,
you feel like,
whoops,
that's more than a fart.
And it's like still in between your butt cheeks.
I've had one,
remember we got that,
I'm down in the South Bay that uh,
it was like some green [inaudible] we're making those blender drinks.
Smoothies.
Yeah.
But it was like,
uh,
all it was called like ultra green or something green all day powder.
Yeah,
Dude.
That thing.
I remember that chart that was standing in the kitchen and I was like,
oh,
here's a cool fart that was liquid though.
Everything came up,
felt it come out,
which it completely soaked the back of the boxers.
Yeah.
But that was not,
I mean,
not your standard.
I mean it's in the Shard scale for sure.
But it wasn't your standard one.
That sounds to me.
Is that a shard or was that a shit?
No.
Well that was what it was a short,
I mean I went to Fart,
right.
And some shit liquid came out and that's kind of,
that's my point.
I went to Fart and some,
a little brown came down and the Brown came out.
Yeah.
So that must be the Mai,
I'm,
I'm leaning towards a shark because we were so much time in between my shower
and then that far that happened.
And then also that,
that's my second sharp because the first one happened over when we were flying
to Africa.
Remember when I showed up?
It's only the second of your life.
My life one have my life now.
Pros,
childbirth.
That whole isn't,
is taught is it used to be.
And I fart constantly.
I can't hold on a farm.
You mentioned that.
Yeah.
And I've also noticed that and observed it and witnessed.
Sorry,
I farted a lot in public on this trip.
Like when I was on the airplane.
I just farted the entire time.
Yeah,
but don't you fart on airplanes?
A art?
Don't you fart?
Like Cree Fart,
right?
Pound farts.
Yeah,
of course.
Well,
cause nobody can hear it.
Oh of course.
Yes.
A R t.
Now I have another addendum to this topic.
I farted on the plane.
Have you ever had a fart?
And I think your dad just brought this up recently that didn't even smell like
your own.
So you kind of question like,
is that my Farnam smelling or somebody
houses?
Yeah.
Yeah,
we did talk about that.
My Dad was saying that he's discovered a new farts.
No.
Right.
What I had was that I flew a few weeks ago,
it was when I flew to Philly and somebody was ripping big farts.
Yeah.
And continuous where I was like,
fuck,
it was the same smell.
And you're like,
God dammit.
And then about three and a half hours into the flight,
I farted and my fart smelled like that.
Right.
That's so cool.
That was weird.
No.
Do you think it,
did you guys eat at the same place in the airport?
Maybe.
I don't know man.
I mean,
I guess it's possible.
Anything's possible.
It's magic.
I Dunno.
Fart Moses.
Yeah.
Wow.
Speaking of,
by the way,
that's Elizabeth May and you remember that?
Uh,
we have a r t a few weeks ago we played her,
um,
let's see.
I'm sorry,
that was me bits.
What happened?
I moved and she got startled and bark.
Oh yeah.
She gets it very scared.
So a few weeks ago we played her,
she's The lady who in parliament was like,
you shouldn't say fart.
Remember?
Um,
excuse me.
But I don't think she's very courtly to say parliamentary.
Well the government talking about skilled labor.
Yeah.
Michelle,
why is it the infrastructure minister talking about how to implement
infrastructure yeah.
To work in Alberta.
Yeah.
Why does this government treat Alberta like a fart in the room?
Nobody wants to talk about or acknowledge.
Oh,
I thought I made that happen because we both did that.
That guys was trying to hold back the laugh part and the wind honorable member
for a Senate.
Chuck,
I'll filings your rough,
my friend and her speech.
But I heard her to say a word that I know is distinctly on parliamentary.
I think she may want to withdraw.
Bird was f a r t tattletale
per title tail.
Right.
No Fun.
No one likes you and nobody likes you.
Elizabeth
at the,
um,
I forget what it's called,
but it's like the equivalent in Canada of the correspondents' dinner,
right?
Like the Canadian,
yeah.
Yeah.
So we're members of government and journalists are together and it's,
you know,
it's a little bit looser night,
but she,
she appeared to be hammered at the scene and was escorted off.
So we showed you last week,
God is here.
I want to mention we stand on his traditional territory too.
And I want to say like,
what the fuck was wrong with the rest of you?
You didn't notice where standing on traditional territory,
what doesn't scream out first nations about this stage?
No,
she's bombing,
bombing.
And then here later,
unusual by you're speechless.
Look at her being escorted off.
Got More class in my whole fucking cabinet.
Thank you.
Wow.
And uh,
that lady,
this lady looks mortified.
She was playing a song from her cell phone.
She was so drunk.
So then,
um,
you know,
we made it a big thing.
Obviously we played it on this show a lot and then we were sent in her
appearance after that.
Yeah.
So after that she made it to jeans.
Uh,
all the news shows in Canada.
Now we've been talking about this all morning about comments from you by the
thousands.
As a matter of fact.
And we want to hear this lady,
she is in Ottawa.
May thank you for being our guest.
Weirdo.
Her teeth.
Wait,
she's got the perfect smile.
It looks like a perfect smile isn't really,
but it's,
it looks like she,
she puts it in like
you do.
Like it's Kinda halfing dude.
Oh well her smile is not perfectly level apologize.
I know in interviews with other news organizations this morning,
having perhaps seen the video again,
a,
any comments you would like to make additionally?
Well,
just to make sure that viewers know that what I was attempting to do was to,
as you do at the press gallery dinners,
and I know all journalists know it.
I don't know how Canadians know it.
That'd be annual press gallery dinner is an attempt at humor and often playing
against oneself in ways that are self deprecating and doing things you normally
wouldn't do.
So he,
you know,
what sucks about that is that it's a,
um,
she's making an apology.
Non-Apology it's,
I'm sorry.
No,
I'm not sorry.
I didn't do anything wrong,
but I'm here to do this.
It's the worst man.
You know what?
You know what the right answer is.
The right answer is I'm,
yeah.
You know what?
I had a few too many bombed.
That was terrible.
Just why can't you just admitted it was,
uh,
it was,
it was a night of fun times and I went a little too far.
I got hammered.
Sorry guys.
Have you ever had a drink too many or is everyone here above that?
Right.
Various stick.
Sometimes sticks.
They fail and mine did not work at all.
It's tempting humor and failed.
I take full responsibility and I certainly course,
yeah,
well that's good.
She needs a lozenge.
She did that there.
She said she did take responsibility.
She goes,
I tried.
It wasn't my intention ever do,
uh,
just the jet to Canadians that I was making a speech.
I was trying and obviously failing badly.
I delivering something new purse.
Had I hindsight,
I should've realized that having traveled so much to the previous 48 hours that
I was probably too sleep deprived.
Pull it off again.
Uh,
to me,
didn't seem tired.
Pretty alert.
Pretty,
pretty groggy.
Maybe seem like you might have been down for a for a long fun night ahead of
you.
Yeah.
She needs to get those bottom teeth fixed to match the top,
the bottom turn yellow.
Really wondering.
I mean,
yes it was the parliamentary.
Rudy's are and he can afford nice teeth.
Him and the guy that wrote Downton Abbey,
that Guy Julian Fellowes,
Julian Fellowes as a horrible bottom row,
I
allow the stairs as we walk the hell put live in there downstairs.
Now you see here that you would never rest your back against the chair and beat
them time.
It's a melon spoon.
Is hourly both scoping as all are?
Yes.
It's a different animal,
but you're still in front of your peers.
You're still making public comments.
You know,
there's still,
people have phones,
chill,
you know,
all of that.
So,
so what happened?
I got wasted.
Just what?
I
was so tired.
I was so tired.
My tits almost fell off when people are go to rehab for exhaustion and our
business like,
oh really?
I actually think that could be real though.
Exhaustion.
It's called throw gas I think and mental illness.
I think if you were to do like the more I've toward when it gets back to back to
back nights I could see you going needing like to check out.
Yeah,
but don't you just stay home for a month?
Like that's the thing.
Is it at home?
You still have shipped pulling at you mental hospital?
I don't know.
I've never had it but I'm saying I could see how if somebody said we're checking
you into a facility to not think about stuff for,
I don't think there are a facility that's like the four seasons,
but that's what they do is they go check,
they check in somewhere for exhaustion.
It's a mental health facility,
but I'm saying I could see how that happens.
I can see I have a too,
but it's usually because it's coupled I think with drugs,
throw gas and mental illness.
I don't think it's just like you're tired.
I think it's more,
but I think at that level of work load where you're traveling that much like day
to day to day and performing and like have,
I think you could be drug free mentally ill free and have it happen.
I do think it's both.
Where are you going?
You go to a mental hospital because you're,
you're well,
yeah,
because your mental state isn't well,
but you're not mentally ill.
You just have worked herself into a state of literal exhaustion.
It was code for,
I have a drug problem.
I need to go and get help.
I'm not disagreeing with you.
My say my thing now is that I actually think no did I think it's real.
I think it's actually legit.
Not drug related.
Yeah.
I get exhaustions.
There you go.
Go check in today.
Hold.
Having a one night that I could do something edgy and humorous given that I am
in parliament,
the person knowing over the last four years,
my record in parliament,
what I've tried to pacify our teeth.
I never hackle.
I never swear.
I'm respectful to everybody.
I've got the idea that has a skit material.
It would actually be funny if I was different from how I really,
nobody cares.
That obviously doesn't work right.
Really giving the explanation,
but she thinks that people know her well enough,
like you know what I mean?
Like
maybe they're,
they do Elizabeth.
So special.
Maybe there are.
They do you have a,
she ain't shit.
She ate her.
She ate her Ted's.
So they don't know her that well.
I guess not.
I Ha I have to ask because many of our viewers have commented after seeing the
video through this morning.
Was alcohol involved?
I don't think so,
but I think I was very sleep deprived and I'd worked at 21 hours a day.
Excuses for myself.
I should not.
In hindsight,
I've thought I was capable of pulling off and edgy because she drank fresca.
No,
I don't think so as I drank,
but I don't think it affected,
it affected me,
which it did.
And they did serve wine with dinner and not denying that.
But I think primarily,
I mean it was just whatever wine the waiter served at our table.
I hadn't been too much for over.
I don't think that was a factor,
but obviously that's what people are saying on online.
And then she's like,
I'm going to,
I'm going to omit that.
I,
um,
I had six.
Yeah.
And then I had that Xanax before the parties.
Xanax.
Yeah.
And uh,
I'll just be like,
is it one is the one that everyone else drink?
Did I have special one?
Was there another glass?
Did they give me an extra fucking,
I don't think so.
I had a bread roll,
I think.
Um,
she gave such a politician's answer like,
Jesus Christ just go.
Yeah.
I know.
I remember what she did at least owned.
She was like,
I was trying to be funny and I just hate shit.
It wasn't Barack the one of the first people to dairy.
Yeah.
I remember when Barry was like,
yeah,
I smoked pot.
Yeah.
I inhaled,
yeah.
Next question.
No,
it's so much better it to somebody just like,
I smoked cigarettes,
so I love cigarettes.
That was kind of story.
He was like,
that was the hard thing for him to stop doing smoking.
Yeah.
He stopped smoking.
I think he smoked even into the beginning of the presidency.
So Rad.
And then,
you know,
they were like,
you can't be the president,
but he's in great shape.
Yeah.
I mean physically he's physically fit dude.
He's in Trudeau shape man.
Yeah.
What do you think's been better shaped rock or two dads?
Trudeau.
Yeah,
he's younger too.
he's younger.
How old buried?
You know,
Barry's got to be probably at this point right around 50,
I think.
Late forties early.
Sure.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I think you turned 50 and office,
so yeah,
he's probably 50,
51 young president.
Yeah,
I'm a old orange sauce.
He's uh,
he's 70 so here he looks every year.
Yeah.
It looks like shit
politician,
not a comedian.
And that went really badly.
Okay.
There you go.
Well,
she did.
She did actually do well.
We,
um,
yeah,
we demanded as people you don't represent,
we demanded that you apologize that way.
I need to tell her what to do with her life.
Yeah.
I just,
you know,
you need to get a perfect smile,
Elizabeth.
We should send her one.
Can we find out where did we can send her mail and parliament.
Yeah,
that's too bad or smells really bad.
Really bad.
You know what the blood flow of the perfect smile is.
They only cover the top.
Oh,
if it's the perfect smile,
it should also be the bottoms.
Yeah,
that's true.
Um,
I got it.
I had an idea to try this week and one want to know what it is.
Yeah.
When you hear
it means that we're going to do our,
um,
our
plugs then or travel blogs.
So that's what,
that's the code for you like,
yeah.
So just real quick,
we'll do it fast.
Um,
I don't know if there's any left,
but I'm at the Ice House.
Uh,
actually this is after that.
Sorry.
It's this already that already came out.
New Year's Eve.
I'm in Orlando,
Florida Horn it up.
Five shows.
Um,
29,
30,
31 new years eve is a special event.
Just a FYI.
It's always going to cost more
than,
than any other night of standup comedy at the comedy club.
Um,
but then I go to Kansas City,
Kansas Shitty.
Um,
and I'm going to be there doing my thing and stuff like that at the Improv,
first week of January.
Then Oxford ox hard in the Ventura county at that levity live,
the new club that's also in January.
And then my big uh,
theater towards starts the first weekend I have New Orleans,
Louisiana Hot Lanta,
uh,
the whore Jah,
then clear farter and then Tallahassee doing a Florida state.
Very excited to go.
Um,
and then you can go to Tom [inaudible] dot com and look at the entire list.
We've added shows and a bunch of cities added in Chicago,
Portland.
Uh,
we added in Mommy Apolis we added in de Trois.
So it's a,
it's a good thing.
Those tickets are going where Christina just was by the way.
Washington.
Dick Holmes.
You're going to be there.
I'm going to March club was announcing it Saturday sold out.
Alright.
Friday has some left.
I know it's,
it's,
it's a far ahead of time,
but those tickets are going to go.
So if you want to come,
I suggest getting your tickets now.
The jeans.
Uh,
should we announce February 12th?
Yeah,
we should announce.
Are doing your mom's house lie at the Irvine Improv.
Now we don't do this show live very often.
It's hard for us to usually travel with baby jeans.
Yeah,
but Irvine,
totally easy.
So February 12th to 7:00 PM show,
get your Sunday as a Sunday.
Sunday.
So it's nice and early on your Sunday night,
you're not going to be out too late.
Uh,
you can get those tickets on thousand ranch.com is it up on your site?
Jeans?
Yes,
at the Irvine Improv.
And then fourth and fifth I go to Phoenix Fart Nicks at stand up live.
May 19th and 20th New York City.
Finally I am doing,
it's awesome.
New York City.
Jude Dork titties.
Gotham comedy club.
Yeah.
I'm so excited to do the city proper and done everything else in New York except
the city.
January 16th to 17th San Francisco man.
Fran disco at the punchline.
Hello Fan.
Fantastic clubs.
And that's it for now.
But stay tuned.
There will be more your tickets already on sale.
Yes,
go 2000 ranch.com per ticket links.
But I'm super stoked to do this show life.
Oh,
this is going to be really fun.
February 12th you guys,
a lot of you have seen a lion or some of you see it live.
Dallas,
Houston,
Seattle,
we just San Diego,
we don't in the ice house a bunch.
This would be the first time in a while.
San Francisco.
We've done a bunch too.
Yeah,
this would be fun.
It's,
it's going to be great.
They're always wild.
Yeah.
And get your tickets now because those do tend to sell out.
We sell the fuck out of your mom's house lot.
Yeah.
Your mom's house.
While I was going to go,
it's going to go pretty quick.
Um,
so check this out.
I uh,
I'm really excited to do this.
A R t f a
r t like dude,
just this morning we got about 25 emails just between Jesus just in the last few
hours.
That's what I was saying.
It's,
it's,
it's hard,
man.
It's hard to keep up with everything,
but this is what happened.
Um,
so I started going through emails cause I was like,
I don't know what I'll have on my computer.
Yeah.
I found a bunch of songs.
Some of them you've heard before.
Some of them I'm,
I'm certain you have not.
Um,
one thing you don't Max Newman.
I love Max Devon.
I asked one of our all time hall of fame musical people.
Okay.
Yeah.
There's like there's ghosts.
Crew will be one.
Max Nouman Ali.
Yeah.
Caesar.
Um,
there's this gaping dad guy.
There's a t P K I think he goes by.
Um,
there's like,
who made like home run songs for us?
We'll Max.
I didn't never knew this was in here when I remember when I was trying to find a
Dj name.
Yeah.
So he was like,
he sent me drops like djs play with different names because he didn't know what
I was going to be.
He's like,
are you going to be Dj Browntown D's a gene briefs,
Dj Beard Flake,
Dj meet Farts,
meet Dj ass gasoline,
Dj bear denim.
That's again.
So he sent me to listen to how funny the,
so this is like if I were a DJ,
right.
And you're coming out of a break.
Yeah.
Dj.
Beautiful.
I go the wars in Jews,
especially the two
Dj again.
Yeah.
We'll make you a mommy.
So lane.
So retarded.
Yeah.
That's great.
Dj Brow down in the mix.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
No,
this is the,
the horns,
you know.
Got Horrible.
Yeah.
You just get caught up in the bear trap.
We did.
I'm dick
bear trap is my favorite.
Yeah.
With Dj Denim Dick and I really like it.
Dj Denim Dick is really like,
he just got caught in the bare tree.
Yeah.
You just got it.
Can I just get caught up in the bear trap?
We team.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
that's good.
Good stuff.
Making those denim skirts.
So retarded.
Yeah,
it's perfect.
absolutely.
I mean he's fucking 100% he's glass and a lot of talent is just glass.
Yeah.
So then I started pull songs,
right?
I mean,
yeah.
Some of these you'll remember,
some of them you might not a,
I don't know if you've ever heard this one.
Here's this one before.
It sounds like Karen,
my Sam tpk
song is called any Cominos balls
speaking.
Oh my God.
These guys,
the song is good enough to actually dance to at a club.
Yeah.
Like if you played this and people were like,
wait,
what the fuck are they said?
We just dance like this is hilarious.
This is,
um,
let's see what this is coming.
Those balls.
This is a wren one is the artists and this song is called Cheerio Hitler.
Remember it from the Hay?
Hitler
[inaudible]
guys ready
if you don't know shit,
that's,
that's the hey Hitler girl.
I guess we should have given you some reference in case you didn't know.
There's,
Danny makes youtube videos and she um,
she begins a lot of them by saying,
Hey Hitler as if he is watching.
Well we discovered that Hitler might be on,
well we think he's in Argentina still only communicating through youtube,
watching you two videos commenting on commenting.
And Danny is one of the few people that knows this cause she reaches out to him
and then they put Hillary.
Then this,
there's another,
yeah,
it's really good.
Yeah,
this was a,
that's good.
This is good.
Brian and Amanda
because she says that
this is a script from one of her videos.
Funny.
Yeah.
Cause it's like she's asked.
That's a great song.
Brian and Amanda.
Um,
let's see.
Is that pop up now then there's tofor Roy made hi mommy.
Hey Hitler.
Hitler.
Hitler is pretty cool.
That was the saddest.
Your teeth are white lifts.
Good God mouth.
Yeah.
You had this shit.
Laughs.
That's really a cool story.
Dj,
Dad,
you gentlemen
to me it's,
is there any Hitler porn out there?
Oh yeah.
We've put
a clip for that.
Incredible.
Your,
your
that's great.
That's what's up with Robin Wright's ass.
Oh really?
Tastes different.
What does,
what a skill,
right?
Really talented.
Good.
Yeah.
Then that we have,
um,
what is this?
All these Caesar and they the double pipe classic song.
So you're hearing that pop correctly.
It should be there.
This is one of my favorites.
If so good.
I love this one.
Right?
These guys are so talented.
Who is this?
This is Ali.
That is fat is fat.
Can I tell you the best thing about Ali too?
To submit songs under a different last name like Ali.
Oh,
starts with an M.
I forgot what it is.
And then he changed it to zs are like halfway through.
It's great.
Well I like all ease,
ease or better.
It's a great stage.
Doing Great.
This is the stage name Max Newman who we were talking about.
He,
I think if I played this once,
um,
when I,
when I was on Rogan I was telling him about problems make by Dick soft.
Yeah.
And how I wanted to make that a song.
So then he made a song right out of me talking about that.
Wow.
Yeah,
sure.
Oh,
it's so good.
No problem.
Oh,
big money.
It's really good.
I can play this too.
It's all big money.
Big Money,
big money,
big money.
This is better man.
99.9% of the dog shit that I hear as opposed,
yeah,
me,
all this music is better because it works.
The conversation about,
as
you'll see,
it's like
the guy like,
hey Joe,
did it go last night?
I did it under my name on his problems,
right?
Oh yeah man.
What is it?
Problem
of course.
Um,
tons of of Bert is fat songs,
you know,
lot of
people,
Tom Scott Thompson and his wife is Dina made a started hashtag why is broke so
fat saying that I'm fat or is in total,
which is not the doctor.
I got the joke,
it just hasn't got wet and it's been like three weeks.
So
she got the modern shopping bombings on social media or Dan Berg.
Fantastic.
Sorry,
I don't know.
This is,
it's not in my file.
Nice.
Facing
die if the spire
crazy.
Martin.
Anything else?
Bars,
bars,
bars.
Your mom's house.
Happy.
Sad hose.
Don't happy hose.
He Sat.
Hosts don't buys for Chrysler.
So sad where it started that lady
for Chrysler.
So how long have we been fat shaming burden for a while now?
This summer I get started around July or August.
I love this.
This is,
this is gaping dad.
It's good.
It's really good.
This one's fantastic.
I haven't gone in voicemail from her in a while.
Yeah,
salivate.
Yeah.
Okay.
That
I enjoy.
That's the Scots,
the Irish guys pocket
bout a Salamay Song.
Hello?
Read this one yet.
Wanted to know what that Farsi Ladies
Buddy,
John [inaudible] children.
Same mom.
Yeah.
So good.
Fantastic to me.
Or the person who's leaving never hears back.
And then there's a
uh,
this is great.
This is gave you that also.
It's a song of vocal fry.
Ah,
yeah.
Vocal
fry.
Anyways,
I was totally impressed.
I love it.
I'm blasting
you guys seriously blow us away.
If you,
um,
if you want to send in your song for submission will be played on the show.
The email as always.
Is he your moms podcast@gmail.com
there's no house in the email title.
So your mom's podcast@gmail.com.
Um,
yeah,
I absolutely love it.
Love it.
I'm excited.
Genes.
You're a family.
That's pretty exciting,
man.
Turning one.
Yeah,
on Wednesday.
Thank God it's been a long year and I'm stoked that he's won.
It's really great to have a party on Saturday.
Your Mom,
your dad come in.
My Dad's coming.
He's one year old.
So crazy.
Some people say one years old.
I know.
It's not plural.
One year old.
Yeah,
no,
a lot of dumb people say one years old now.
Stupid's it'll officially make them a toddler,
right?
I think so.
I think once I start walking,
they're considered toddlers.
What about this person do you think?
Do you think this person is also,
hi everybody.
Hi
everybody.
Because everybody is coming from me.
I'm not a baby.
I am a man,
Nigga,
Nigga.
Oh
yeah,
that's that.
What else is going to be like?
I am not baby.
I'm 22 my name is Jonathan.
I am my phone Santo Domingo.
You think he has that disease?
The Webster thing where you're like,
oh man,
what an adorable black kid and I'm 38 man.
Yeah,
he's a forever puppy.
Yeah.
And then don't talk to me.
You look like David.
I am not fucking baby.
He's real serious about it.
Well I from Santo Domingo,
Dominican Republic.
Hey,
I loved the yard.
That's where we saw a hardcore pornography in our hotel room.
Remember that was the best hotel are we ever stayed at?
I wish we would watch so much more.
I was like ready to like just do that for a few days.
That was so funny.
Hardcore pornography or hotel channel 69 too.
So weird.
I remember at the end we took a survey and then they said,
what was your favorite channel?
And I put 69 with a winky face or the free pornography.
So weird to say.
What was your favorite channel?
It was on the survey.
Remember they don't think like Americans.
You know what I'm saying?
Did you have a favorite channel while you were here?
Okay.
Amen.
He's really sick of got that disease.
Yeah.
People are that.
What if,
what
if next week it's uh,
our son's birthday party and we give them the cake and he makes his wish and we
say happy birthday.
And the first thing that pops out of his mouth is,
I am Nigga.
I be like,
you are your father's son.
A baby.
That'd be so fun.
You know what?
I'm actually a little,
if you said I'm not a baby,
be a,
I'd be,
that'd be hilarious.
Yeah.
Like I'm a little concerned because
of the,
the aggressive farting and burping that you and I do in front of him.
Now he's starting to understand a lot of this stuff.
He understands everything that you say.
Yeah.
He can't really talk back.
But like we have the fart chair in the morning that you've been sending on.
Yeah.
And that it's going to be a problem.
Our son's going to have problems.
Yeah.
I
don't think he's not going to be doing that.
That's going to be his future wife.
Yeah.
And that's going to be like,
he'll be making videos like,
hey was here,
got another big burp coming up
king ass rapper as a child.
Yeah,
but,
but can I tell you,
I'd rather have him data girl.
It can do this.
Yeah.
And some dumb dumb.
Some girl who's like uptight and lame.
Well,
what kind of girls up type in lane.
Girls don't rip 'em like that.
Yeah.
I want him to date the kind of girl who's like,
I have come all over my face.
Come on.
My
God,
I hated that lady.
I remember when the guy called me gene,
that was so great.
He didn't look professional at pluralize.
Jane Jane has everything.
All right.
And you didn't correct him.
That was my favorite.
If I was like,
it's jeans Polero sir
diffused,
but he also would have been,
oh,
I'm,
I'm sorry Jean.
Yeah,
Jean.
Uh,
we got more,
somebody else sent,
um,
a drive through.
Really.
I love these.
Yeah.
Thanks.
[inaudible] me.
See if I can get jeans forward.
This thanks genes.
Thanks Mommy.
Can I tell you another thing that we were talking about at breakfast this
morning?
Because Ellis is one,
almost one year old now and he can finally kind of feed himself.
Like he'll,
he'll pick up whatever you put on his little tray and like mash it into his
mouth.
Yeah.
And I remember your sister Maria,
when Weston was about,
I dunno,
six months old.
Yeah.
We were like,
oh,
is he eating solid?
She goes,
yeah.
Weston loves salmon and men Chieko cheese.
And you're like,
there's no way a six month old baby like salmon.
He loves caviar as cargo,
a Beluga caviar and Sushi really down.
It's babies.
Wants Pasta
and like Cheerio's my,
our son lives on cheery outs.
There's no way if we put salmon down he'd be like,
fuck your salmon salmon.
It tastes Ne,
I want give you some nasty,
which I,
salmon smoked salmon.
He doesn't,
he likes,
uh,
he likes to actually like sat on our Bagel.
It's interesting.
Yeah.
She's so crazy with that shit man on a Bagel.
I give him a whole big all let them check on it.
Yeah.
So fucking weird.
It's weird.
Yeah.
He's uh,
she,
uh,
she has her own way of doing things for sure.
So what are you looking forward to with your folks coming?
Um,
how are we going to mass with your mom?
Most importantly,
how are we going to mess with Bourbon Fart in front of her,
in front of the kid and she's getting,
probably get upset about that.
I'm going to do that stuff.
Nothing I want to do is have her read ridiculous copy.
Like come in here and be like,
Hey,
I need you to do this for my show.
And just give her like,
have it written.
What should we have a read?
Oh,
just I'll have a read as rap stuff.
Just resay drops,
you know,
have,
do Jess glassine yeah.
Should we sit?
Should we show the glass and thing?
Glassing glassing Haverty just glass and,
um,
I can't wait to see your pots,
dude.
He's my faith.
He's top dog is adorable.
He's going to love the baby of that.
You know what I love about your dad is that he has no problem chillin.
Your Dad is the chill.
It's like he'll come,
I can,
I know now they're going to come from the airport and then chills like too hard.
Too hard.
I'll come,
I'll come in for five minutes,
be like,
all right,
let's go back to hotel.
And that's how,
by the way,
that's how you know I've done a couple of father son drips with him and he wants
to do,
he's,
he was wanting to do one this year and I actually regret that I didn't,
and he wants to do one next year.
And I'm like,
yeah,
of course we'll,
we'll do a,
we'll do one.
So he,
um,
he goes like,
we go on trips and we get there and he's like,
check in,
you know,
you get something to eat and you're like,
okay.
And then you go and as you're eating he'll be like,
let's go back to hotel chill.
And I'm like,
okay,
I'm gonna get there.
And then we're like in bed,
like,
you know,
we're like sharing a room.
He's in one bed and [inaudible] good time.
Right?
I got it.
Yeah.
And then he's like,
wait,
I gotta get dinner somewhere.
I don't go to go see some shit or something.
We do that and then it's like,
let's go back and chill again if we look to do,
that's what I like to do.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess I kinda like to do it too,
but he's like an extreme version.
I think the only bummer part about having a kid for me.
Yeah,
no chill time.
And for me,
I'm,
I'm as lazy as your dad.
Actually,
my natural state is reclining constantly and I really liked that about him.
Yeah.
He likes,
by the way,
you've picked up the habit of I'm done eating.
I'm going to go.
Oh really?
And you get up and you leave.
Remember we were eating dinner last week and he,
first of all,
there's no talking now when you eat,
it's like silence.
I have to talk to Ellis.
Yeah,
he doesn't talk back.
you just,
it's silence.
What does silence and then you get up and you clear your plate.
And I'm like,
Tom,
we're not done yet.
And Alice and I are still sitting here.
Then what did I do?
You fart.
No,
I stayed.
Right.
Cause then you go,
oh yeah,
sorry.
Yeah.
Wow.
You hear that one?
Yeah.
I Dunno man.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
sorry.
it's going to get worse obviously.
Oh,
I know.
We become our parents.
It's inevitable.
I know.
Signed up for this shit.
Boy.
You think I fucking love this shirt?
This might be my favorite,
favorite,
favorite ever.
Ever.
I want one so bad.
Okay,
well they're going to messenger one over today,
right?
I'm getting one over here.
I'll have another one ship to you.
Um,
oh my God.
I love it.
It's such a good design,
Anthony,
uh,
merchant method who we work with,
glass glass.
It's so silly.
It's so good.
It's so good for the hardcore fans going to cry
and the audience in DC.
My favorite thing was to see everybody's shirts like it.
And you could see it from the beginning of why I made sure there was an old
school top dog shirt.
There was some Theo shirts there.
Was You with cane?
Yeah.
It's so rad.
Like to look out.
It's like a catalog of all the memories of the show.
Kind of connect with somebody.
You're good.
So we're really excited.
It's the just glass and shirt order now.
Try to get it in time for Christmas.
Just glass.
So stupid.
Yeah.
He's super stupid.
Sounds
so stupid.
We made sweet love.
Yeah.
And you showered beforehand.
I thought that was really when you stop with that.
What are you talking about?
When you brush your teeth every day?
All the time.
Yes.
I do.
No nonsense.
Not before we make sweet love,
which this would have played after we had sex.
You just get caught up in.
That would have been cool.
Just glass and um,
I really love this shirt.
Yeah,
that's great.
Go to Tom [inaudible] dot com click on the store and it'll take you to our,
our,
our merge page.
Or would you rather you do,
I don't have,
would you rather music,
but give it to me.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Okay.
I came up with it today.
Would you rather make browns without the use of the toto washlet three 50 e
yeah.
Forever.
Or
not be able to floss.
Ooh,
forever.
Wow.
You have to choose between going back to taking Moshi bear dumps.
We're going back to being the disgusting animal who doesn't floss.
I would take no more flossing.
Wow.
Yeah.
Walk me through the logic.
Well,
I'm thinking of,
first of all,
how much I enjoy the toto washlet three 53 50 e and all of its magnificence and,
and just unbelievable technology and I love the clean feeling of a post Brown
washlet.
I know.
It's like impossible to go back.
You can't go back in time.
Yeah.
Um,
there's,
there's times where I've wanted to floss whatever,
don't floss.
You just don't floss and you're like,
fuck,
this is whatever.
But you have gross.
It's gross.
But you go,
I dunno,
you,
you know,
you still can rinse your mouth.
You brush your teeth,
you,
you could get a Waterpik,
you could do all these things that are kind of,
well let's do this.
Let's take out the Waterpik.
You can't do that because that's a form of flossing.
Okay,
well I think you could still,
you could be really more thorough about you're brushing.
You could do more thorough.
It's not,
it's not the same but your,
that's something away.
But it's like,
do I want to floss and then have that dirty birdie bottle all the time.
And I think the answer is no.
Well,
here's the thing is that I would choose not having the toto washlet three 50.
He only,
because I just go shit to shower anyways.
Like I feel like that's always been my toto washlet sure.
But not flossing.
Like,
you know how it is after you eat a steak and there's just chunks of meat in
your,
between your teeth.
There's nothing grocer.
It's disgusting.
And if you can't like brushing doesn't always get those chunks of food out.
I know you have to floss.
Yeah,
pretty fucking gross to not floss,
but it's just the way it is,
man.
I'm going to,
I'm choosing it's a would you rather,
I know,
I know what were opposed on this?
Yeah.
You would take no more brown so no more clean browns.
No,
I would just go straight to the shower like I always did before the toto,
that was kind of your,
that was kind of,
I feel like there was a,
would you rather that I really liked there was you sent it to me.
Really?
Yeah.
I'll you want me to find it?
Okay.
Just talk for a while.
I'll find it.
Okay.
What just Todd for awhile.
Yeah.
Sometimes you guys send really good ones.
So I um,
uh,
let me see,
is this the one?
That's it.
What'd you rather,
nope,
that's not it.
But I know there was a good one.
Good one.
And you go,
oh,
this one's great.
Let's read it.
If you can find it.
There it is.
Okay.
Ready?
Go for it.
How is that?
La La,
la La.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
You are stuck in a small queen bed,
motel six hotel room for 30 days with either king ass ripper or John Soccer's
full on carrying
out their famous antics.
Okay.
Pause right there.
Yes.
We inform people kicking ass rapper who normally I would play a drop of his,
the Fart God.
Uh,
he makes the,
the fart videos in his tighty whities and he just lays in bed.
It gives the double thumbs ups as he lets out like these crazy long farts and
he's got like Brown stains and his underwear and it's horrific.
Right?
John's soccer's Vegan enthusiast who makes songs about veganism and he has the
Deacon Vagina and how he,
he makes,
you know,
ridiculous songs,
comedy songs,
all about veganism.
And He's told,
he made a video where he wants to eat every woman's vagina if they're Vegan.
Oh,
so stupid.
Um,
okay,
so that's just a set up.
So they are,
there's those two.
You share a bed with them,
have no contact with the outside world and no form of entertainment other than
whatever you and your person of choice choose to do for fun.
John Soccer's is allowed to bring an acoustic guitar for him.
Oh my God.
The king can bring one extra pair of clean underwear.
Food and drink are unlimited,
but you must follow their diet choices.
Exactly.
Which will be delivered through a tray slot.
So I was to avoid outside context,
whatever they choose to eat,
you eat,
who becomes your 30 day roommate.
I hope contemplating this fantastic choice makes you reveal those million dollar
smiles.
I appreciatively Steven.
Right.
Thank you.
Steven Wright,
the comedian.
Famous comedian.
Right.
Thank you for listening.
Um,
uh,
I think that's a really good,
would you rather it got me to thinking personally.
I like king ass rubber more.
There's no,
there's no question for me.
Oh No.
But 30 days locked in a room that is disgusting to be with him.
It's vile.
It's,
it's revolting.
And I'm going to go with Sean,
John Soccer's,
oh my God.
And here's why.
Annoying.
Oh my God.
It not as bad as revolting and I feel like he would annoy me.
There's on some level he would,
um,
you know,
he knows so much about veganism that he would educate me and I'd be like,
all right,
I'll learn about this.
Yeah.
But I'll learn.
So I'll be like,
all right,
I'll learn.
Um,
I would end up probably wanting to write a song with him so I wouldn't be like,
oh this is third.
Get out some creative juices,
have some fun.
Um,
eat healthier.
He's going to feed me his diet so I'm going to eat healthier.
So it's going to be a healthier 30 months,
30 days.
Um,
if you live with king,
asked ripper for 30 days,
it would be KFC,
baked beans,
fear.
He would fart all day everyday to the point where they're going to be probably
shit cause he,
he does Brian,
he sharks like you did all day.
It's going to smell like fucking hell in that room.
It,
it's going to be taught.
It's not 12 hours.
Listen,
it's only 30 days of your life.
So 30
day it's a month you eat poorly for nobody else will eat eggs.
Don't forget,
he likes to eat dude.
He farts on them first.
He's going to Fart on your food.
He's in charge of the food.
I know so,
but here's the thing,
John Soccer is,
we'll try to lick my vegan vagina the whole time.
You know Vegan,
he'd be disgusted by you.
Yeah,
but I'm disgusted by him.
At least king as ripper is not a sexual fucking predator.
John Soccer's is too sexual for me and it would creep me out and he would try to
hit on me the whole time.
King Astra has no interest in women as is obvious because he puts out fart
videos and burp videos.
I think you're so far off on this one has no interest in me sexually and that
would be the main reason I'd go with King ash of her and I like farts and burps.
I laugh at them a lot.
Yeah,
but you open a window.
What do you think my life with you is like?
It's not that far off.
You think I'm on king after uppers level you please.
There are some days you're almost as bad as aspirin.
Yes dude,
there's one but Ali and okay there's one and yes,
you put that Goddamn fan next to our bed so you fart into the fear hasn't been
on since we've been here.
And then the fan blows the fart in my face.
You've been doing that for years.
I am.
I am used to this fan on tonight.
I am learning this to this art torture and tonight f a r.
T I'm used to this kind of behavior to me that will be like you in tidy whities
from Oh thank you,
your honor.
Come here.
Let me tickling like that guy.
I love that guy.
I hate him.
I think he's awesome.
Uh,
so nasty talk last week we played that for a,
I think his name is Orlando is articulate it this way.
Know what?
I don't like it.
I got new stuff for you.
I took it that way
in that diamond is always a plus a bitch.
Oh my God.
I like him.
Diamonds in the crab is per se.
So
turns out we were like,
Oh,
who is this guy?
And he's a a known guy.
Yeah,
he was on,
that's so raven,
which is so that's so raven.
Orlando Brown is his name.
Uh,
he did Vlad TV and interview.
So check out the diamonds in the crevice of your pussy guy giving an interview.
I'm like,
God will speak in it.
Speaking of Raven and Mickey Mouse,
you had that line and no fear.
Yeah.
You know a lot of them talking about so many months,
so many miles to suck my suck.
Like Raven did what?
She was black.
When you hear that rat a tat,
I suggest you Nigga Scott.
Oh yeah.
Well I mean just that.
Wow.
That's pretty good.
What do you mean to say?
Like Raven did when she was black?
I mean,
I told you in the first interview,
she gave me
and I gave her some,
but I do,
I do.
Yay.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
So
he's saying that he ate ravens box.
Yeah,
she's pretty,
yeah.
There's no reason.
There's nothing weird about that.
I'm just saying he has an interesting way of showing it.
So interesting is that you and I have been going to tender Greens lately.
That's become our jam.
Yeah.
God bless tender Greens.
You and I are huge fans and lately we've been seeing people with throat tattoos
a lot and he's got,
it's a good move.
I think if you're looking to put yourself into a,
uh,
a cat and a unique category where there's opportunity,
there's um,
originality,
there's no,
no threat,
perceived threat of your behavior.
It's the um,
it's the choice to get a throat peace and good for customer service.
Absolutely.
When you walked to the register,
yeah,
we went to our tender Greens and this really cute 20 something year old girl.
Super Nice.
I mean super sweet,
but it's an aggressive,
uh,
it was a cat right on her throat,
like a big one too.
And I imagine when she envisioned it,
it probably didn't feel that severe in her mind.
And then when you get like a black cat,
it's pretty severe.
It's really,
she was like five feet tall,
so tiny,
tiny.
She was like her head down looking at the register.
Then it looks up and you're like,
oh my God.
And there's another tender Greens employee that has a throat tattoo as well.
There was to throw tats are aggressive.
I don't know what it is about tender Greens,
but they're employees are covered in an aggressive tattoos.
Not that I don't oppose it.
I think it's entertaining.
I know,
but I'm not so sure that's where you want to go as a business model.
You know you got family people coming in there and not everybody is as open to
the throat tattoo as you and I are.
No,
it does limit your job choice.
What do you mean you're worried?
Tender Greens
that you work at attach shop.
Yeah,
the job stoppers.
Right?
Your work at a knife store.
There's tender Greens,
the knife store,
pet store maybe.
I think you want to stay away.
I've always,
you know,
retail is hard.
I think face is not the best idea.
And then I also want to throw in throat.
Yeah,
I think it's an addendum to the face tattoo that you had.
Yeah.
Clearly either your Mike Tyson and that's it with the face tattoo.
Very few people can pull those off.
Very,
very few and by a few I think we mean one.
So yeah,
it's,
it's always a long or would you rather get the throat cool tattoo of the cat?
Like the one that that girl or you get the Tyson and it's as an homage to him
and people know that you and he are acquaintances.
That's a little much on the fan blowing out to be like,
Hey,
I got a tattoo.
Like did it on my face.
Like here's my thinking is that if you were to do the face tattoo and people
know it already,
they would go,
oh,
Tom Segura loves Mike Tyson so much that he did an oh my gosh,
he's crazy.
He's mentally,
but you're going to get that anyways for the throat tat don't you think?
Yeah.
That's really scary to see.
I think,
um,
I think it went with face.
They go like,
okay,
I know what I'm dealing with here.
And I think when someone sees that throat tattoo,
they're like,
what am I dealing with?
Right.
That's when you level,
because I feel like the throat tad is dot.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's gotta hurt so bad.
So tender the,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
and then just,
and then she has a,
she had a filled in black cat.
Yeah.
So there's color in that thing.
He goes over and over and just what's up,
bro.
Yeah.
And when you look at someone and they have the,
and then the crazy thing is that somebody with that throw tattoo immediately are
going to be like,
oof.
Right.
You're going to see it and they're going to be like,
what?
You know what you did?
You know what you fucking did.
It's the same thing as like,
uh,
when a woman has like the see through the shop.
Yeah.
And they're like,
what are you looking at?
I'm looking at your big stupid tits cause they're out.
Yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
Well,
why?
Why can't I just do this and you don't mind.
We'll,
because everybody's looking at put them away.
Stupid.
Yeah.
Don't you slut shaming me like no sweetheart.
Put a picture of a Nobel prize.
Get over here and I'll take her your pussy.
You know?
No,
but you didn't say,
where are we going for it?
You said throat over face.
Okay.
How about this?
Let's change,
let's change the game.
It's a face tattoo.
But any face tattoo you want,
you can get a teardrop.
You can get,
it's hard to decide on a face tattoo stars like Kat von D's got up.
I mean,
I would try to hide it.
I would,
I would do like an e under my beard,
you know,
for my sons initial or something.
But you can't hide it.
It's gotta be visible.
Visible.
Well,
I'm going to have facial hair.
What are,
what happens now?
It's gotta be like a teardrop,
like a gangbanger dude.
Come on your forehead.
No Way.
It's a knife.
Yeah.
No,
I'm not doing that.
He like Charles Manson clan.
Oh,
a swastika.
Yeah.
Originally they were exes and then later turned to swastika to x amount of
society.
I read a lot of stuff about Manson when I was growing up.
Dark side of the forest.
Can Pal,
cork,
Iran.
So what do you choose?
You're evading the question.
I do actually feel like the throat is crazier.
I think,
I think I would go through the face.
I think I would go through the face and you know,
I get,
I would get a dot on my nose somewhere.
Then I have a big black cat.
Yeah,
I'll do that.
You know what I would want you to do?
I think you should get your eyebrows filled in.
Oh,
cool.
Yeah.
Like why won't you do the haircut I want you to get,
now that we're talking about this stuff,
will you tell the audience I've asked you to do this multiple times?
First of all,
I
don't think this is as funny as you do and you laugh hysterically every time
we're laying in bed.
Just kind of like joking.
You Go,
why don't you shave the top of your head and give yourself a friar tuck?
Yeah.
You buzz the top and then you leave the,
the sides around it like a horseshoe.
See,
look how happy you are.
I don't even think it's that funny.
And you think it's so funny.
I think it's a great idea.
Um,
I don't think it's that good.
What do you mean?
I don't like that?
Why?
No,
and you can't just get a dot on your nose.
You have to get,
there's rules because the throat piece is like this.
Okay.
Yeah.
You have to get at least an inch,
an inch long,
an inch wide and in your face because the throat pieces way bigger and it's
solid.
It's not fair.
What if you,
what if you inked in your beard so you wouldn't have to grow on anymore?
That's a pretty good idea.
Maybe I'll do that.
You could tattoo eyeliner.
I a lot of women do that.
You know they tattoo makeup on women.
No,
my step mom did it.
She tattooed on her eyeliner and you can tattoo lipstick looks fucking terrible,
but you can.
Isn't that the craziest thing you've ever heard to tattoo your lipstick or eye?
Why would you,
why is it that important to have makeup on all the time?
So weird.
No,
no,
no.
What are you looking at?
I'm trying to find a picture.
Text.
Google Friar Tuck.
I did already.
And it's not,
it's not the exact hair hair cut.
I want you want a Mohican?
It's the last of the Mohicans.
It,
that's what that is.
Google last of the Mohicans.
Last of the Mohicans.
Yeah.
It's like a,
it's an Indian thing.
Not,
not,
uh,
the cowboy,
not diarrhea.
Indian.
Okay.
The cowboy.
Um,
well,
here's the images that come up,
like kind of that guy is when I was thinking,
I feel like it's a reverse Mohawk so that the top is gone and to reverse Mohawk.
Let's see.
Um,
what is it?
A fryer.
Friar Tuck company.
Get a Mohawk.
They look so good.
Haircut.
How about for a woman though?
That's the best.
Can I give Elyssa Mohawk when he's older?
Yeah,
of course.
Seriously.
Of course.
Oh my God.
I love it.
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
yeah.
That's it.
No,
that's not how I've enjoyed it.
I want you,
here's what,
okay,
here's the idea.
God Damn Nice people out of it.
Or we saw,
I saw one picture of it somewhere.
Um,
I want you to shave.
Look,
yeah,
right here.
The top out.
So it's like when a man is balding,
like normal mail.
Yeah.
The horse shoe and then have all the hair long on the sides around it.
It's a friar Tuck,
but at the Friar Tuck it looks like it goes all the way around though.
That's the difference.
The Friar Tuck,
does anybody know what that Hairdo is called?
That my husband?
Yeah.
Which one?
This one?
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
Um,
how about
like male pattern baldness?
Oh,
in women.
Women.
Oh,
I'd hate to have that.
Yeah.
It's not what I had in mind.
And I want you to create it.
Um,
horseshoe horseshoe or,
yeah,
that guy's hair.
It's hilarious.
The Circle.
Okay.
We get the point in time.
Yeah,
you get the idea.
But I want you to like this,
like this guy's hair right here.
See?
Right.
All shaved on top,
but long you're at longer.
I think that'd be real.
Give me if I did it honestly,
I would really give you whatever you wanted because I think it'd be in,
I think you'd end up thanking me though,
because you'd be like,
wow,
like this is a really cool haircut,
but I can't really do that.
Is there some other version I could do to get something from you?
I mean,
why?
Why do you think you can't do it?
You're going to stand out so much.
Can we fill your parents?
Can I get a fake throat tattoo?
Yes.
We've got to get on it though.
They're coming soon.
We got to get on it.
What would you get me for the Friar Tuck a car.
You want a car for that
baby?
It's going to ruin everything.
I can't do stand up.
I can't do.
You can do stand up.
It's going to give you such a boost.
You're going to be,
you'll be on the today show the next week if you do that because they'll be
like,
have you seen how cool this new comedian is?
They'll think you're new,
but you'll you'll,
yeah,
or your throat.
Oh,
Dick.
All the way.
It would hurt a lot.
Yeah.
The whole thing is what do you put on there?
Your son's name?
No,
we put a message on there this way.
I saw one that had the word poison with an Arrow pointing towards the tip.
That's funny.
Yeah.
That's a pretty cool denim deck.
Wait,
so you did it dick over.
I'd put like these jeans need to get tell you what,
if you got fingerless gloves tattooed on your hands
or the throat.
I liked the idea of fingerless gloves tattooed on my Dick,
so it looks like someone's holding it.
I like that idea too.
But for this,
would you rather have fingerless gloves tattooed on full gloves?
Tattoos?
Fingerless it's such a homeless deck to have fingerless gloves or a bad look
throat cat at that checkout at tender green.
I'd go for the fucking horrific gloves and it has to be become part of my
persona.
Like you're holding a mic so we're targeting would be like,
wait,
why are you doing the dice there?
I'd be like,
Oh fuck.
And hickory dickory dock man.
Do you know how long it would take to Tattoo fingerless gloves?
I'm sure someone's done it.
We'll see if someone,
you'd have to do an image search school and they're like,
it's,
no,
that's a tattoo.
Such
a crazy,
I didn't know.
It might be the craziest thing I've thought of in my life.
The fingerless gloves tattooed on your hands.
There's nothing worse than that.
There's no worst tattoo than that.
It's pretty bad.
The throat.
Ted's pretty aggressive,
but that just says,
I'm fucking out of my mind.
That's a really dumb thing to do.
Or is that,
is that a tenant like that?
It's like Henna though.
No,
no,
no.
Those are just a real nice,
it's a nice pair of gloves to tattoo of fingerless gloves.
Yeah.
Fingerless gloves.
I hate fingerless gloves.
What is the point?
They don't keep anything warm.
The whole point is to keep your fingers,
Warren.
I am glad you still gives you that grip.
Your fingers can get out and take care of things,
but I like to drive with them.
Do you remember that?
That was a wedding gift for one of my friends.
It's so funny.
Justin gave me fingerless gloves as a wedding.
No,
he gave each one of us
together were a pair of finger.
I still have it in our,
one of my favorite things.
So funny.
Yeah.
This guy is a little muddy.
Well,
what do you mean by that?
She was black.
Part of what she said.
So she no longer black.
That's what she said.
How she didn't say that
would be bad.
Yeah.
Well,
how'd you feel when you heard her say that?
I feel,
I felt like you dumb ass.
Don't you know that the Cosby's wasn't predominantly black show mother fucker.
That show audience.
Hilarious
Day.
I mean,
like I said last time I stand by her if she feels like she's Brittany Spears and
all by God let her be Britney Spears.
Goddammit.
Mr. Lane called me.
I don't give a shit.
Oh,
hey.
Hey.
Now Orlando Brown
made another video about looking at breasts.
Yeah,
the Areola Areola,
right.
Well you said,
you said that she didn't,
she had clear every artist.
I said there was,
the whole titty was one color.
We usually the are different colors.
Let me tell you something.
Look,
no.
Takes Him all right now.
I said they will fucking name.
Let me tell you something.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's happening.
Yeah.
So now it's Raven has one titty color that's not that unusual.
My boobs were all one color pretty much before I had Ellis and now they're like,
I'm kind of an expert in those.
They,
they were not the nips.
We're not that different.
Yeah.
They were like,
I was very pale and now it's totally different.
Now I have like purples,
mushy purples.
That is going to be the name of the next of my hour.
Mushy purples.
Why not?
I know.
I kind of like it too.
It's so fucking good,
man.
Unless you purples purples and now they are.
They're mushy and the nips or perps now everything's purple.
So weird and it hasn't gone back.
Write a bit
about where she purples.
I'm Gunna,
okay.
That's a good name.
I did.
It was,
it was.
It looked like it had a category.
What does a cataract is?
You ever seen her?
She don't want dogs.
I know it's,
it's just,
it's,
it's all one color around it.
It's just a big,
a big pink penis.
He did.
Yeah.
He's talking about Ravens titties.
Do you like that watch?
I'm going to get that for you.
You love watch us.
It's only $25,000 I'm going to take out a mortgage on the house that's more than
that.
Unless it's probably a fake.
Can I take out a second to get the absolutely for a watch.
It's a brilliant idea.
Do you remember my favorite thing ever is when you called top dog and you told
him we were so poor by the way are cute and so sweet.
We were living in the rampart division.
We had no money.
And you said to your dad,
dad,
how much I'm going to spend $100,000 I said I'm going to lease a Lamborghini.
And he was like,
okay,
I'm going to go.
So we've got to put this much down.
And it was like something like 2,500 a month.
There's more than 2,500 that's it for a lambo.
No,
no.
I was telling him like it's,
I got,
you know,
we borrowed some money putting like,
you know we've got like $20,000 for a down payment and then a lease payments at
least like 2,500 it was like more than our rent at the time.
Quiet.
And then you know,
we're going to give up this and that and the whole idea is that all,
um,
when we go to,
I'd go to stand up and people see me pull up,
they'll be like,
oh,
like this is like a significant guy,
you know,
big deal.
Yeah.
And you know,
this is a business of perception and stuff.
And he was like,
well,
if that's what you need to do and the best part is again,
and I was,
I was waiting for him to be like,
don't do it.
The best part is I can get it gets 10 mile per gallon,
10 miles per gallon.
I was like,
and I only can drive it like a thousand miles a year.
So I have to really,
really be careful of how often I drive it all the time.
He goes,
if you know,
I understand that that's different business.
So,
so sweet.
Totally was supporting my dad would not be supportive.
Yeah.
Not at all.
No,
no.
What am I dads say last time my dad's spins,
stealing our grapefruits.
We talk about this.
I don't remember if we talked.
He,
I remember he was like,
I remember from when I first met you,
weirdly,
one of my oldest memories of you as you telling me how much your dad likes
grapefruit.
He just fucking love science.
I love it too.
It's,
yeah,
it's in the genes,
but yeah,
no,
so he texts me,
he doesn't come over.
I,
he's seen Ellis.
My father seen Ellis maybe five times since he's been alive.
My son,
since we moved into this house,
we got two or three grapefruit trees.
[inaudible] and my dad texts me,
I might come over and get some grapefruits.
Okay.
And I'm like,
all right man.
And he comes and he goes,
oh,
it's too high.
The three is too high.
I'm going to go to the store,
I'll be back.
He goes,
he comes back the next day and now he's got a tool that the actual grape grape
fruit picker,
this motherfucker is now pulling down fruit from our trees and a lot too.
I was like,
all right,
get like a couple,
right?
Yeah.
He's out there pulling for like an hour every day.
He said,
and he stole maybe a whole back.
My memories of of grapes are Charro.
She Oh she,
no,
she never eats the hot in their back yard.
Oh,
that's why.
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
she's a slice grapefruit and pour honey into a little pocket,
like a little squirt and then that's how she would be great for it.
I want a grapefruit,
but so he bought the thing,
the picker I now he leaves you that are around,
you know,
my side of the house.
That's the only reason he comes to steal fruit.
No.
And then he like waves to the kid.
Did he even hold Ellis on a Thanksgiving thing?
So we looked at him.
He looked at it,
but what?
He's done a good job or anything.
Oh my God.
But he did.
He did.
He was like,
oh.
He goes,
you know,
they're still young now.
It's like there's not much to do with them.
You know,
as a grandfather,
I go,
yeah,
cause no four or five does when you can do things.
I'm like,
oh,
he'll be back in about four or five years.
Yeah.
See you then Kiddo.
But what was saying like there's not much like not happening.
He's only learning to talk,
walk,
stand.
Uh,
develop a sense of self and separateness from his mother.
It's not a big time.
Not a lot going,
but he was like,
there's not much I can do.
Right,
right,
right.
My favorite was when he heard us saying good job to Ellis to learn to eat.
Good job.
He goes,
I don't know the same good job too much.
I think you say good job once at the end of the day he said one good job.
Not,
not all the time.
Yeah.
Cause otherwise you're saying it too much.
Too much.
She's like,
I hear these people,
women who are like,
oh you did a good job.
Good job.
Good job is too much.
Too much.
I can't wait to tell you said to tell your mom that story.
I think the Turner explode and what she's going to go like.
Wow.
Cause your,
your parents are the opposite.
Oh my God.
Very loving.
Well.
And they're also like,
they applaud,
like you say,
applaud a shit.
Tommy took a shit.
Everybody gather round.
Let's take a picture.
Oh,
I know.
Every,
every move.
They,
they,
they think it's the best thing ever.
Absolutely.
Look at your self esteem.
Look how successful you are through the roof.
Through the roof.
Yeah.
No,
that's why I look to you for guidance and guys,
speaking of self esteem,
uh,
the weight loss challenge is ongoing.
Um,
a slight update.
Uh,
I've been really good.
I've um,
uh,
made some adjustments to the Diet and I don't want to give away too much because
then why,
why should Burke a benefit from you or your knowledge?
Just know that I'm,
I'm fully immersed in this competition.
When you're winning,
I'm eating well,
I'm doing my exercise and let's just say the numbers are a changing.
Yeah,
well cause births on Instagram.
I saw he was an Indian apple today and he's partying.
Yeah.
Can't lose weight when you're partying.
And we'll see.
We'll have to see what happens as they like to say.
I might tell you what happens.
He's fat.
Yeah.
Well,
there's no doubt about that fast kind of permit,
but Nah,
man,
I mean that,
that I said all that to say it's just bullshit.
I said nothing.
He said nothing.
I said nothing,
man.
I said,
I said enough to get people to watch and they watch.
Yeah,
you just did.
Yeah.
Silly goose.
I liked the guy.
I gotta say I like him in the crevice of your pussy.
I don't like when he juggles it and stuff,
but I like him.
I think he's,
he's a cute guy.
He's in a,
I don't know,
he's a cute guy.
He's a nice guy.
He's handsome.
Um,
Bandana.
But I liked how he looked in the other one.
He's got nice teeth.
I feel like you have a real strict policy on leftovers.
Um,
it's like when there's food in the fridge from the day before,
you're like,
is this all right to eat?
I don't like,
yeah,
it's from last night now.
Like,
uh,
I think we got to,
I'm like,
that's the whole point of taking it like in a bag to go home.
Not True.
You're talking about Sushi leftovers,
which you should not store Sushi and then eat it two or three days later.
That's not three days later.
That's crazy.
Of course.
I never do that.
What I do do three days later,
just fucking insane.
She like a day later,
which I think you can definitely do.
You can have dinner at Sushi dinner and put it in the fridge and have it the
next day.
I disagree.
I think that
properly.
Maybe the,
maybe the Sushi chefs,
they store their temperature.
You have fish.
Are you have an ally and not necessarily a Sushi board?
Leftovers as plies.
Plies has an opinion on it.
To explain to some of y'all when I just had to tell my mom,
you bought it though.
The leftovers away.
That wasn't wasn't bad.
You're pushing it Sunday.
Monday.
Yeah.
You still eating them leftover
hospital day.
Then at the bottom line for the though,
that's a good point.
He says Friday is the best it's going to taste.
He's right.
He's saying he's using Thanksgiving as an example,
so he's thanks.
Thanksgiving,
the food obviously the next day,
most of the two left.
His primary laughter is the best day you saying right?
The next day.
The day after day after,
which is my point.
So they're after is fine.
I think you're pushing it by Saturday.
Saturday.
Okay.
Wednesday you're doing the cooking?
Yes.
Okay,
so it wasn't I Thursday's the day of Thanksgiving.
Wednesday night you're prepping and Thursday you cook,
you cook it,
the rest of it you eat Friday's fantastic.
I'm throwing them out by Saturday.
God,
seriously.
Yeah.
You can definitely have some of that on Saturday can I don't think,
I'm not saying that you can't,
I don't think.
I think really pushing it with all of that kind of food with Sushi.
I definitely think the next day is fine.
I don't think so.
I I don't it's fresh or nothing with raw fish are out of your fucking
yes,
that's right.
And get a match refrigerator.
Yeah,
that's right.
He's right.
He's right about everything is right.
Yeah.
We haven't heard from him in a while.
We'll apply.
I know it was sweet pussy Saturday.
Can I tell you something?
Your teeth looks so much better that you've widened them.
So that was my dental update.
Um,
I was going to do dental update today,
but we mentioned that during one of the songs you're like,
great.
Remember the other night I told you,
you look healthy,
you look like you eat right.
Here's what I did.
I told her,
I go,
remind me,
remind me last week when we were doing the show and then I was,
you were gone and I was about to just wind down and I go,
do I want to go and get the trays and then go in the fridge and you have to
think.
And I was like,
and I go,
well,
I just asked for a reminder.
I'm just gonna fucking do it.
So I got the trays ready,
got the shell.
Did it burn?
No,
but the next morning my teeth were aching.
That means it works.
Yeah.
If it burns the next day and it's tender to heat and cold,
that means you,
you burn the shit out.
You get that layer of,
oh my God,
they look,
I didn't do a Giuliani.
I did tops and bottoms.
Let's look at Rudy's teeth.
You want it.
It's either nasty,
nasty,
Rudy Giuliani.
His teeth are the worst and he can afford better teeth.
Dude,
fix your fucking teeth.
Weird beard.
He said this guy,
God damn,
he's a weird dog.
He's a weird dude.
Let's see.
Yeah,
the tops look aggressive.
He's got one shot of him.
Yeah,
it's terrible.
It's when he's talking.
Ah.
Oh my God.
The bottoms are just rotten yellows.
That was a real bad names that you're so nasty,
Rudy.
You got to fix that buttery popcorn all over the did.
He's got dad mouth for sure.
Like bonded.
There's aren't even like,
those aren't the days veneers.
Those are the ones I used to have.
Right.
He's got his from the 90s still.
I think he needs to have a free fixed,
fixed this whole,
just go do the whole thing.
And the veneers they do now are amazing.
They're glass.
They're translucent.
Those are the old ass ones that were there.
Just like chalk.
Yeah.
They're
not see through.
They're not translucent.
Right off.
They look like fake choppers with a bottle.
Those are yellow and tartar felt.
They look really bad.
Can I tell you something?
A lot of people say he just cares about the upper class,
you know?
Can I tell you some real talk?
Yeah.
When you and I are 60 years old.
If you have a mouth that's like this,
it's full of tartar and yellow and brown.
Guess what?
Yeah.
I'm not kissing your mouth and I'm not putting my mouth on your junk either.
Yeah,
of course.
Nasty.
Shouldn't cause you're going to get done at that.
That issue.
You go get the nice high quality.
Yes.
Just have a nice face every 10 years.
15 years.
Got To have your teeth redid.
Yeah.
Sorry.
That's the fucking cost of admission.
We don't want it to white like Dennis.
Uh,
no because
didn't get the good ones though.
Yeah.
He got Shitty,
shitty.
Even you've got to go to a specialist and they'll do,
they'll make even like age appropriate veneers.
They'll be like,
well we'll,
we'll make them fucking billboard wide.
We'll make it look so it looks like you have nice teeth.
Yeah.
For your age.
Kind of goes with your skin,
like you know.
Yeah.
The,
the natural.
They follow the shape of your natural tooth.
Yeah,
that sounds stupid.
The guy looks terrible.
Yeah,
it looks fucking terrible.
He looks like a a skeleton,
like a skull head.
You know those big fight fake white choppers.
Never stop.
It makes it last night we were testing audio.
It didn't stop making me laugh.
I still laugh at
the fucking go down right there.
All right.
Do you ever seen a moose coming down right quick?
Oh,
oh God.
I was raised.
That is awesome.
Such a dad boner.
I can.
Garth Brooks went hunting.
Yep.
We got out here early board and look at the look at the metal.
This is why,
this is why we came up here.
When we bring the,
sounds like it's going to cry to battle big,
long,
tall metal.
We'd been slipping along here.
Just glass and just glass and glass and all of a sudden literally I had even
hoped,
I didn't even put my head in it all.
I'm like,
oh,
we're just glassing.
He pictured by those.
Is this for a TV show or this is just,
this
is youtube.
Youtube.
Dot.
It's so funny.
I found who he was.
Oh yeah.
Tell me everything.
Yeah,
he,
he's a big time hunter.
Like he's,
he's a well known boost moose hunter.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm here.
Let me pull up a
you guys name.
Oh,
the Moose just glass glass.
Let me do a timeline.
And you know what?
I usually have a snarky thing to say for people.
I,
I just love his joy.
I have,
I have nothing Shitty to say about the dad.
The Moose Dad.
Like,
he's so rad.
He's a nice guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well you can tell he cares about his family probably.
He's probably an an just a nice dude.
Um,
okay,
so here I am.
Let's see.
Pepper Chutney.
He said Angel Pepperoni's.
Just a sweet little angel dog.
Okay,
so I put this,
uh,
oh yeah,
the shirt up and that's how it,
it.
Uh,
people started telling me who he was,
just glass and his name.
Hold on,
hold on.
I'm going to give it to you.
Just people were like,
I got a huge dad boner for this.
How do I see the video?
People put it up.
Give me a second.
Yeah,
apparently he does.
He does guided tours too,
you know,
so if you,
if you want to go hang out with the glass and dad with the glass and guy,
you can,
yeah.
Holy Shit.
What's his name?
His name?
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to pull it up.
Just give me a second talk.
Talk.
All right.
Um,
I,
I still feel like he is Canadian though.
I hear a Canadian thing and the Moose hunting element to me is Canada,
so I don't know where the fuck this guy is from.
I'd like to know more about his story.
I think he's still from Canada.
I don't care what you guys fucking say that you ride any got from Canada.
How can you say that?
I don't think he sounds American.
This guy sounds Canadian.
Come on.
F A r.
Here it is.
Okay.
And here is,
what's the Red Fred who's name is Fred.
Fred Eichler.
Yup.
There you go.
Here we go.
I'm going to look them up for you.
I did this yesterday and I lost the,
uh,
he has a passion for bow hunting.
You know,
clearly America's favorite hunter.
It was so,
I was Canadian born and maybe he's Canadian boring.
Fucking know that Shit,
man.
Of what about Fred was the same amount of personal achievement and his passion
for bow hunting is taking them all over the world in pursuit of his next
adventure.
Fred truly believes that any animal with a bow is a trophy.
Okay,
his personal,
any animal with a bow.
Okay.
It's personal quest to complete the North American super slam with a recurve bow
reflects that state of mind.
And Mid August of 2009,
Fred harvest at a cow tool elk to become the first to take all 29 North American
big game animals with a recurve bow and complete the super slam.
Fred has been fortunate enough to share his love,
enthusiasm,
and support with fellow hundred and it was a country,
blah,
blah.
Who gives a shit to a way of life.
He loves it.
He absolutely loves it.
Real die hard.
North American Super Slam.
Now.
See,
that's why it leads me to believe he is Canadian because we don't refer to it as
North America
American here.
You guys got a family.
Yeah.
See?
Oh,
this guy is on the level.
Family Guy.
Three guys.
Three boys home about Fred.
Contact Fred.
Fred's gear.
I'll see a glass insured.
Why aren't you glass and Bro?
I was the stuff that he hunts with his arm bands.
He has a real deal.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Anyways,
that's the guy,
man.
I,
I'm a huge fan.
That is this guy right here.
Fred Eichler.
There you are,
bro.
Just
came up here.
Yeah,
it's amazing,
right?
Let's just keep going.
Let's glass glass,
glass,
glass and I'm like I said,
I'm like,
holy smokes.
It's never not funny.
Holy smokes.
Loose class.
Such a dad Canadian thing.
Holy.
Oh no,
he's not a park boys.
We got a hundred fucking Canadian emails saying like your ears are full of
blacks.
No,
I was born in Canadia,
Windsor,
Ontario.
Proud Windsor native.
I'm telling you,
I feel like this guy's Canadian.
F A R t guys.
Oh my God.
Look where
proud wins are native
Fred.
I Claire from people who've already been typing it
probably from this show.
Okay.
Let's see.
Goddammit.
Friday there's a Fred Eichler fan page.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Maybe he'll maybe,
yeah.
Shit.
Okay.
We'll send them an email.
Let's ask him where he's originally from because this guy is,
if he's hanging out with Canadians,
maybe.
Yeah,
cause I hear a little,
oh my God.
Here we go.
Okay,
fine.
Fucking email shit right now.
Oh,
you got an email?
Just glass of class.
Class class.
Maybe we should wait until after the show.
No,
I'll do it right now.
You're going to type out an email while talking to each other.
Is that fun for the audience here?
And See.
Keep talking,
man.
I've got another had fucking how could you not think of anything to say?
All right.
What do you mean you can't think of something about this?
I uh,
you guys were talking last week about the,
uh,
the Super Bowl and how stupid the music is and how stupid.
What is it all just fuck,
fuck those balls.
The whole theme songs
on a Sunday night and Monday night football tonight.
You're gonna love it.
And we were talking about how the corporations have ruined all these uh,
stadium arena names and how oppressive
and depressing that shit is.
Same thing goes for,
um,
children's things because we went to go to Tarjay to get Ellis' first birthday,
like got decorations and all I want is like,
Hey,
uh,
do you have like a tiger or how about some trucks?
But no,
no,
no.
You have to have the Disney cars.
Uh,
three thing like even on the cake,
on a birthday cake.
Can I just have a fucking truck?
The kid likes trucks.
Well we have a Disney cars thing or a despicable me part three fucking character
thing like you guys do.
When,
what happened?
That just making shit that kids liked.
Now it all has to be sponsored by Pixar and Disney.
It's really depressing.
Yeah,
it's really crazy.
I feel like I was at the end of 60 minutes there.
Is that morally Schaefer's Oh yeah.
Where he has like a rant that your dog,
when a car doors slams,
it makes a noise.
Did you know that people work on that noise?
That was one of his one time about the way that a door on a car sounds different
from car to car.
People working on that to make the car doors.
They're French.
Okay.
I wrote where's Fred phone?
We are a big fans.
We enjoy your heading videos.
We want to know where her friend was from and where did he grow up?
Thanks.
And keep hunting and keep glasses.
I can't tell him that.
Keep glasses.
You're like,
wait,
what?
Yeah,
he won't understand that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Sent.
All right now it's just a matter of time.
Yeah.
Well we'll find out.
We're Fred's relief relief
from class class class.
Um,
all right.
That's silly.
So there's all these wonderful songs.
Which one do you want to hear you on the way out?
There's pastor pudge.
Jyske a sermon 74.
There's my dad's balls.
Well my dad's boss listen to that one.
Okay.
In honor of your father coming.
That's right.
My father is coming.
Um,
it should be fun.
thank you guys for listening to the show.
We love you.
Oh,
February,
February 12th.
Come see us at the Irvine Sperm Vine Improv Improv.
We're doing y h lie.
Five,
7:00 PM.
It'll be great.
See you guys soon.
Goodbye.
Dad taught us not to be shamed of art,
especially since they have such good size at all.
It gets bigger when I'm pulling
sometimes
bowling.
It's so hard.
I've written the skin.
Give Him Dad.
That's a gaping,
gaping dad gave him dad.
That's a gaping dad.
Okay.
I have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad's phone.
Have my dad's Dick.
I have my dad's Dick.
Right.
I need my dad's fault.
Oh Man.
Dude.
Things too.
Like how not rip the skin by using someone else's mouth.
Steady your own hands.
Okay.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I have my dad's sick.
I need my dad's book.
I have my dad's Dick.
Have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad.
Both
dad had caught up not to be ashamed of our dicks.
Hmm.
Her Dad taught us not to be shamed of our dicks.
I have
have my dad's Dick.
I have my dad's Dick.
I need my Dad's,
have my dad's Dick,
have my dad's Dick.
I have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad,
both my Dick.
I have my dad's Dick.
I need my dad's book.
I have my dad's sick.
I need my dad.
I need my,
yes,
I have my dad's sick.
I need my dad.
That was really great.
It's so deprived.